now both the secretary and as a veteran
of our afghan war
my thoughts have been with the brave
americans
who stood up to serve after al qaeda
attacked us on september 11
2001.
and my heart is with their families and
loved ones
and with our friends and allies
and with our fellow citizens whose lives
were lost or changed forever
over 20 years of war
we remember 2461
american service members and personnel
who paid the ultimate price in this war
and more than twenty thousand wounded
americans
some still carrying the scars that you
can't see on the outside
we also remember the thousands of
american contractors who lost their
lives
hundreds of our allies and partners from
nato and beyond
and tens of thousands of afghan soldiers
and police officers
and tens of thousands more
afghan civilians
now we have just concluded the largest
air evacuation of civilians in american
history
it was heroic
it was historic
and i hope that all americans will unite
to thank our service members for their
courage and their compassion
they were operating in an
immensely dangerous and dynamic
environment
but our troops were tireless
fearless
and selfless
our commanders never flinched
and our allies and partners were
extraordinary
the united states evacuated some 6 000
american citizens and a total of more
than
124 000 civilians
and we did it all in the midst of a
pandemic and in the face of grave and
growing threats
i am incredibly proud of those who made
it happen
and they made it happen with grit
and skill and humanity
our outstanding men and women showed
steady judgment under crushing pressure
including some very young service
members who summoned up exceptional
courage
at close quarters
they ran an international airport
they sped up visas
they fed the hungry
they comforted the desperate
and they got plane
after plane
after plane into the sky
our forces risked their own lives to
save the lives of others
and 13
of our very best
paid the ultimate price
and many of them were too young to
personally remember
the 9 11 attacks
united states
military will always
honor their heroism
we mourn with their families
and we owe them support
through the days and years ahead
it is noteworthy that
on the day of the attack at the airport
our troops and their partners pushed
hard and carry on
putting 89 rescue flights in the air in
a span of 24 hours
and lifting
500 souls to freedom
it has been an enormous achievement not
just by the us military
but also by the militaries of our allies
and partners and of course
by our teammates at the state department
now the war is over
and we're entering a new chapter one in
where our diplomats and our interagency
partners take the lead
we're part of an urgent team effort
to move afghan evacuees out of temporary
housing
in intermediate staging bases in the
gulf and in europe
and on to begin new lives
and i'll be traveling to the gulf next
week
to thank our partners there who have
done so much to help save and shelter
afghan civilians
now
some of those brave afghans will be
coming to make new lives with their
families in america
after careful screening and security
vetting run by our interagency partners
we're temporarily sheltering sheltering
some of these evacuees at military
facilities here at home
and i'm proud of the way that our
military communities have welcomed them
some of these courageous afghans fought
alongside us
and they and their families have more
than earned their places
in the land of the free and the home of
the brave
and welcoming these afghans isn't just
about what they've done
it's about who we are
now
as one mission ends
others must go on
and even during our afghan retrograde
this department was racing to help
victims of natural disasters at home and
abroad and we still are
we've been driving to to end the
pandemic
and we've continued to tackle security
challenges from china
and russia
iran and north korea
it's our duty to defend this nation
and we're not going to take our eye off
the ball
and that means relentless
counterterrorism efforts against any
threat to the american people from any
place
it means working with our partners to
shore up stability in the region around
afghanistan
and it means a new focus to our
leadership in this young century
to meet the security challenges from
china
to seize new opportunities in the
indo-pacific and elsewhere
and to deepen our ties with all allies
and new partners
and to defend our democracy
against all enemies
but for today
i want to end with the word to the force
and their families
i know that these have been difficult
days for many of us
and as we look back as a nation
on the war in afghanistan
i hope that we will all do so with
thoughtfulness
and respect
i will always be proud
of the part that we played in this war
but we shouldn't expect
afghan war veterans to agree any more
than any other group of americans
i've heard strong views from many sides
in recent days
and that's vital
that's democracy
that's america
as we always do this department will
look back
clearly and professionally
and learn every lesson that we can
that's our way
but right now it's time to thank all
those who served in this war
because you
are the greatest asset that we have
you
the extraordinary men and women who
volunteer to keep us all safe and your
families
so my prayers are with you
and with the gold star families who lost
loved ones in afghanistan
and with the warriors who mourn
their fallen brothers and sisters
and with those who bear the wounds of
war
to body and to soul
we will never forget what you did
and what you gave
our country owes you thanks
that won't fade
and support
that won't falter
the war has ended
but our gratitude
never will
and finally just a word about the navy
helicopter mishap overnight off the
coast of california
i know the navy is working diligently at
search and rescue operations
and on behalf of the whole department
i want to pass on our thoughts and
prayers for the best possible outcome
it's yet another reminder of the dangers
our men and women face every day
overseas
at sea
and here at home
now let me turn it over to the chairman
thanks secretary and good afternoon
everyone
three weeks ago
the united states military received the
mission
to conduct a non-combatant evacuation
operation from afghanistan
in support of the department of state
in order to evacuate american citizens
the department of state
designated afghans
with a
directed completion date of 31 august
the key military tasks were to secure
and defend
the international airport in kabul
evacuate all embassy personnel
evacuate all american citizens that
wanted to get out
and evacuate other afghans as designated
by the department of state
and retrograde all
of the u.s military
in short
the united states military was tasked to
conduct two
highly complex
missions simultaneously
a retrograde while in contact with the
enemy
and a neo in a non-permissive
environment
we executed that mission
in a highly dynamic
dangerous operating environment
from a war-torn country
and was conducted across nine countries
and 26 intermediate staging bases and
temporary safe havens
we deployed between five and six
thousand military personnel on the
ground
some of whom were forward deployed based
on our contingency planning
these elements came from the 82nd
airborne division
special forces the marine corps
along with navy and air force personnel
flying in support for combat aircraft
from the air force and the navy
as well as incredible support
from the transport aircraft the pilots
and crews
of the united states transportation
command
and afloat we had an argument
and a carrier strike group
we flew 387
us military c-17 and c-130 sorties
and we enabled 391
non-us military sorties
a total of 778 sorties
evacuated a total
of 124
334 people
which included
almost 6 000 american citizens
third country nationals and afghans
designated by the department of state
and we will continue to evacuate
american citizens
under the leadership of the department
of state
as this mission has now transitioned
from a military mission
to a diplomatic mission
evacuees flowed through
the intermediate staging base safe
havens and central command
and european command
for onward movement to the united states
a third country or their home of origin
for repatriation
evacuees complete medical and security
screening vetting
in accordance with the lead federal
agencies guidance the department of
homeland security
currently there's approximately
twenty thousand evacuees
in seven staging bases in five countries
in central command
another twenty three thousand in seven
staging bases
in four countries
in europe
and as of this morning there are
approximately twenty thousand afghans
who arrived at eight different military
bases
in the continental united states
this mission
cost 11 marines
one soldier
and one navy corm in their lives
and 22 others were wounded in action
in addition to over 100 afghans killed
and wounded
in a horrific terrorist attack on 26
august at abbey gate
on the southeast perimeter of the
airport
those soldiers sailors and marines
gave their lives
so that others may live free
they literally gave their tomorrows
for the tomorrows of people they never
knew
those hundred and twenty-four thousand
they never knew the thirteen who died
and they will never know that twenty-two
who were wounded
with the thousands of dead and
thousands of wounded who came before
them
but they will now live in freedom
because of american blood shed on their
behalf
nearly two decades have passed since
that horrible dark september day in our
nation's history
when
2977 innocent lives
were murdered
since then
the men and women of the united states
military and our interagency partners
have fought tirelessly
to defeat terrorists in afghanistan and
around the world
both at home and abroad
their talent their efforts
have carried this fight day and night
in afghanistan our mission
our military mission
has now come to an end
and we're going to learn from this
experience as a military
how we got to this moment in afghanistan
will be analyzed and studied for
years to come
and we in the military
will approach this with humility
transparency and candor
there are many tactical operational and
strategic lessons to be learned
800 000 of us in uniform
served in afghanistan over the last 20
years
our nation spent over a trillion dollars
and most importantly 2461
soldiers
sailors
airmen
and marines
gave the last full measure of devotion
well 20 thousand
691 were
wounded
and untold thousands of others
suffer with the invisible wounds of war
as we close this chapter
in our nation's history
and all of those casualties
are alongside our allies and partners
and we should never forget
that 60 000
afghan national security forces gave
their lives in the conduct
of this war
our counter terrorism efforts in
afghanistan the region
over 20 years
has protected the american people from
terrorist attack
and the men and women and children who
had just evacuated
will ultimately be the legacy
to prove the value of our sacrifice
for the past 20 years
there's not been a major attack on our
homeland
and it is now our mission to ensure that
we continue our intelligence efforts
continue our counterterrorism efforts
continue our military efforts
to protect the american people for the
next 20 years
and we in the american military are
committed
to do just that
for those of us in uniform
who served in afghanistan
for our families
who have suffered and sacrificed along
our side
for those who have supported us
these have been incredibly emotional and
trying days
and indeed years
we are all conflicted
with feelings of pain and anger
sorrow and sadness
combined
with pride and resilience
there are no words that
i or the secretary or the president or
anyone else
will ever do to bring
the dead back
but we can always honor them
and one thing i am certain of
for any soldier sailor airman or marine
and their family
your service mattered
and was not in vain
thank you
okay i think we have enough time for a
few questions and we'll start with you
bob
thank you mr secretary um
looking ahead in afghanistan a question
for both of you please
given the experience of the past couple
of weeks at the kabul airport
where u.s commanders were
coordinating or at least communicating
daily with taliban
commanders
to an effect that general mckenzie
himself said was at times very helpful
and also i know general milley in your
case you uh last year had face-to-face
meetings with taliban leaders at least
on a couple of occasions
i'm wondering what you can what you
think these experiences say about the
prospect for the united states
relationship with the taliban
to include the possibility of any kind
of
coordination in
counter terrorism operations against
isis k in afghanistan
well first of all let me applaud the
initiative of our commanders
on the ground
who
would stop at nothing
to accomplish the mission that they were
they were provided of evacuating as many
american citizens third country
nationals and siv applicants as possible
now we were focused on
we were working with the taliban on a
very narrow
set of issues and it was just that to
get as many people out as we possibly
could
and so i would not leap to i would not
make any
leaps of logic to you know a broader uh
to broader issues
i would just say that uh again i'm
immensely proud of
of uh what uh what our troops have done
to this point and it's hard to predict
uh where this will go in the future with
respect to the taliban
and i would uh just say bob um
you know secretary and i both served in
afghanistan and many of us did and you
all did too
um we don't know what the future of the
taliban is
uh but i can tell you uh from personal
experience
that this is a ruthless group from the
past
and whether or not they change remains
to be seen
and as far as our dealings with them at
that airfield or in the past year or so
in war you do what you must
in order to reduce risk to mission and
force not what you necessarily want to
do
any possibility of coordination against
isis k with him
do you think
it's possible
going forward bob i again i would not uh
want to make any predictions
i would tell you that we're going to do
everything that we can to make sure we
remain focused on isis k
understand that network and
the time of our choosing in the future
uh hold them accountable for what
they've done
let's go to helene cooper
thank you sir for doing this i have a
question for you and then another one
for general milly
mr secretary perhaps it's possible that
there's no exit from afghanistan that
would not have been
chaotic
given what we now know
and for all the reasons that the
administration has mentioned
uh
but i would like to know now in
hindsight is there one thing that you
wish that you or the pentagon had done
could have done differently
uh thanks celine um
i would just tell you that there hasn't
been a single operation that i've ever
been involved in
uh where we didn't discover that there's
something that we could have done
better or more efficiently or more
effectively
and i'd also say that no operation is
ever perfect
i will tell you that we will do what we
always do and that is to to look at
ourselves and
do after action reviews
and and we want to make sure that
we learn every lesson that can be
learned from this experience
but i want to take the time to uh to do
it the right way
and uh and so
we'll do that in the days uh in the days
ahead
sorry
i was just going to say i i would just
say again helene that i'm enormously
proud of our of our men and women who uh
who worked hard to accomplish
uh what they just accomplished which i
think as i said earlier is historic and
heroic
go ahead you may be thrown out the book
on the whole sib i mean the previous
administration did
leave i understand that i did put a lot
of hurdles in the way of the siv program
that this administration had to then
deal with upon arrival
do you think at all that because the
pentagon worked so hard with these
people for 20 years these translators
and interpreters
that we should have thrown that whole
book out
what i would say helene is that the siv
program is obviously not not designed to
accommodate
what we just did in evacuating you know
over a hundred thousand people
and so uh perhaps uh this this program
should be looked at going forward uh it
is a it is a
designed to be a slow process
uh secretary blinken and and in the
state department worked hard early on uh
to
uh to shorten the timeline that it takes
to to work your way through that process
but again for the type of operation that
we just conducted
i think i think we need a different type
of capability
i wanted to ask you about sunday's drone
strike
can you take us back to that morning you
have intel that isis k is plotting
another attack the military spots a
vehicle that you believe is
full of caring
explosives
uh and we take the car out with a drone
strike and reports now say that we made
uh that 10 civilians as many as 10
civilians may have been may have been
killed
because of the urgent threat environment
at the time do preliminary assessments
indicate that we may have rushed relax
or waived altogether some of the normal
checks and balances that we do before a
strike like that
a couple of things one is as we always
do on all of these things we initiate an
investigation we're reviewing all the
the video and all that
uh but having said that you know what do
we know what we don't know what do we
think sort of thing
at the
at the time and i think this is still
valid
we had very good intelligence
that isis k was preparing
a specific type vehicle at a specific
type location
we monitored that through various means
and
all of the engagement criteria were
being met we went through the same level
of rigor that we've done for years
and we took a strike
so that we did secondly
is we know that there were secondary
explosions
because there were secondary explosions
there's a reasonable
conclusion to be made that there was
explosives in that vehicle the third
thing is we know from a variety of other
means that at least one of those people
that were killed was a isis facilitator
so were there others killed yes there
are others killed who they are we don't
know
uh we'll try to sort through all that uh
but we believe that the procedures at
this point i don't want to influence the
outcome of an investigation um but at
this point we think that the procedures
were correctly followed and it's a
righteous strike
so we've got time for one more question
and we'll go to barb for the last
question thank you sir
um
well your message is today from both of
you your messages of compassion
and gratitude are certainly understood
in the last several days both of you at
multiple times have issued these kinds
of
messages and statements
and what i'm curious about is what do
you see in the country
with troops with veterans
that
makes you
feel
it's a rare thing that makes you feel
these messages must continue
and you you have put out so many
in the last few days and general milly
i was very struck you used the word pain
and anger and that you understood that
was out there
so as a combat veteran yourself of
afghanistan
can you help people understand that
where
does your pain and anger come from if
you could both answer your views on this
i'll start by saying barb that this is
the longest war
in in our history
and so
uh there have been
uh a couple of generations that have
participated in the in this war
and
in
as we've gone about i've gotten input
and reactions that are from all sides of
this uh of this issue
and as i said in my my opening statement
that's to be expected
and
and of course
i respect that and i think we have to
provide ourselves
the time and space to adequately deal
with with everything that our veterans
have been through
and we will work through those issues
and and the system will be there to
support our veterans as we work through
those issues
i just think
again we need to respect each other's
views
and be supportive of each other
and one thing i would say barb is that
people will process this differently
and for those who think they need help
please seek help
you know we're there for you
and as i said you heard me say
a number of times before you know mental
health is health period
uh and and so
this will take time to work for people
to uh to work their way through there
are
varying opinions
on on each side of the aisle and that's
to be expected and respected so
can you assure
the question
so barbara you asked me where my pain
and anger comes from i have all those
same emotions and i'm sure the secretary
does and anyone is served
and i commanded troops um and i wasn't
born a four-star general
uh i have walked the patrols and been
blown up and shot at an rpg and
everything else
my pain and anger comes from
the same as those grieving families the
same as those soldiers that are on the
ground last night i visited the wounded
up in walter reed
this is tough stuff war is hard
it's vicious it's brutal it's
unforgiving
and yes we all have pain and anger and
when we see what has unfolded over the
last 20 years and over the last 20 days
that creates pain and anger
and mine comes from 242 of my soldiers
killed in action over 20 years in iraq
and afghanistan so yeah i have that but
i'm a professional soldier i'm going to
contain my
pain and anger and continue to execute
my mission
thanks we have to go we have to go guys
be sent back to afghanistan
[Music]
you